to look at the
tomb of the unknown soldier in arlington
virginia
on this veterans day we are thinking of
course of everyone who have served this
country and everyone who ultimately gave
their lives
for this country and their families
exactly commitment as well yeah i think
it's such a good time to remember this
is so much more than a day that things
are on sale or the bank is closed and
you don't get your mail
this is very important to acknowledge
the people that have sacrificed for this
country
there is no america without our soldiers
those are exactly right we say thank you
on this day
yes we do all right welcome back to cbs
this morning
on this veterans day a cbs news
investigation reveals concerns
about how some former service members
are being treated for what's called
the signature wound from the iraq and
afghanistan wars
since 2000 more than 400 000 u.s service
members
have been diagnosed with a traumatic
brain injury
but a whistleblower who spoke
exclusively with cbs news
says one v-a hospital was dramatically
under-diagnosing tbi
leading decorated veterans to be denied
treatment
with tragic results chief investigative
correspondent jim axelrod is following
the story jim good morning
good morning the va medical center we
are focused on this morning
is in new orleans and that's where
whistleblower worked who's speaking out
for the first time
telling cbs news that from 2009 to 2019
doctors at the southeast louisiana
veterans health care system
failed to properly assess hundreds of
combat veterans
for traumatic brain injuries
on the front porch of this home in
franklinton louisiana daniel murphy
decided he could take the pain
no longer and so on august 21st 2017
this 32 year old retired army sergeant
who did
five decorated combat tours in
afghanistan and iraq
hanged himself do you blame the va for
what happened to your brother
absolutely jim murphy was daniel's older
brother
i've been fighting this for a long time
to try to get
closure hold someone responsible because
my brother should be here
sergeant murphy's combat mission was
detonating explosives
honorably discharged in 2013 after more
than a decade of service
he suffered symptoms of post-traumatic
stress disorder
insomnia anxiety a feeling the enemy was
lurking nearby
but jim murphy told us there were also
signs of brain damage
like memory loss so dna wasn't like that
and he's like
are you sure he couldn't remember basic
stories of your childhood
not at all we could sense that something
was wrong
he knew something was wrong with himself
you feel different
until last month dr frederick sauter ran
the family mental health program
at the new orleans va a psychologist
with three decades
treating vets with ptsd sauter grew
suspicious in 2017
about the quality of care where he
worked i was noticing that many of them
were having headaches having memory
problems things of that nature
many of his patients with ptsd a
psychological condition
were also presenting symptoms of a tbi
a physical wound but hadn't been
diagnosed
or treated for one then i said you know
to myself
there's a problem department protocol
requires all iraq and afghanistan vets
to undergo a simple four question screen
for tbi
during their first visit to a va
facility a positive screen leads to more
evaluation
according to internal documents obtained
by cbs news
60 to 80 percent of vets who screen
positive nationwide
are ultimately diagnosed with tbi but
when dr
sotter dug into the data he was alarmed
the number at the new orleans va
18 it was so deviant a number
i remember thinking i should just turn
the computer off forget what i've seen
look away
look away you know and
i couldn't do it instead sauter says he
compiled a list of vets who had first
screened positive for a possible tbi
but never got the va mandated follow-up
there were hundreds
these are people who need to be
identified they need to be brought
into the va evaluated it has to be
explained to them what their problem is
and what the risks are
and they need to receive special
treatment from the va
nearly 600 vets had further evaluation
conducted by this man
va neuropsychologist dr john mendoza
sauter says dr mendoza diagnosed tbi at
a rate of 9 percent
lower than both the va nationwide and
the va in new orleans
three veterans told us dr mendoza told
them
he quote didn't believe in traumatic
brain injury
so how can you have doctors working at
the va who don't believe in something
that the dod is called the signature
wound
says something terribly bad about rva
he hated that place hated the va hated
all the doctors
why he just no one ever heard them
two va sources confirmed daniel murphy
reported he'd been diagnosed with a tbi
years before when his humvee hit an ied
dr mendoza's notes also indicate murphy
complained of memory loss
and yet while dr mendoza diagnosed ptsd
and depression
he wrote there was nothing presented to
suggest
possible tbi without a tbi diagnosis
there would be no tbi treatment six
weeks later
danny murphy took his own life the last
thing that my brother texted me was hope
to talk to you later
it was that evening that he he hung
himself
and it's it's haunting i see the pain
yeah i miss him
dr mendoza did not respond to our
requests for comment we can
tell you he retired in 2017 several
months after he saw daniel murphy
the va declined our request for an
interview but in a statement to cbs news
the department said
it is quote committed to safe
well-coordinated care
for those who have sacrificed for our
nation tomorrow
we'll tell you what happened when dr
sauder raised his concerns to be a
leadership
story that may be even more disturbing
than what we saw today
wow jim this story is the story itself
is haunting and so upsetting
how strong are the links between
traumatic brain injury
and suicide anthony that's the context
this whole story is unfolding in because
research shows vets with traumatic brain
injuries are more than twice as likely
to die by suicide
and dr sauter told us his fear is that
there are many more
daniel murphys out there all right jim
we'll look forward to your report
tomorrow thank you